ryan asks i got on bumble today looking
for someone to
i can't even say this on it looking for
someone to
do a thing to me that would feel
pleasurable but
turns out you must agree with black
lives matter now to get laid by
strangers
should i delete all dating apps and just
look for love at church let me know
there is so much in that question there
is so much
because it is absurd
that now when you go on this like app
that is basically just there for people
to gratify their fleshly desires
you need to profess some high-flying
political ideology
that is actually based and promotes
lies based on and promotes lies there's
that side of it
there's also this kind of absurdity that
we live in a culture where people
just swipe all day waiting to gratify
their fleshly desires and then some of
those people
see no discordance between doing that
and then going to church where you might
find love as well
a great question a profound question
probably for a whole number of reasons
it would be better for you to look for
love at church
or i don't know a bar or some
yeah probably that area i i totally
missed online dating culture
i just barely missed it but i did miss
it i never have been on any dating app
or anything like that
and i got to tell you i'm really pleased
i'm really glad
that's a part of the culture i'm glad i
missed because
it seems very enjoyable if you're a
single person particularly if you don't
have many inhibitions
but you know in a way you're
you're giving up so much of yourself
you're putting out these pictures to
kind of attract mates and you
you've got all these flirty or explicit
messages back and forth and it seems
like such a time suck and
i don't know it doesn't i kind of like
the old-fashioned way better so
go for the old-fashioned way in most
things go for the old-fashioned
[Music]
you